so the communication between neurons is
fascinating because neurons actually use
electricity and chemistry to communicate
so they use an electrochemical gradient
to produce electricity within a single
cell and so to understand how one neuron
communicates with another neuron you
first sort of have to understand how one
section of one neuron communicates with
another section of a neuron because
neurons can be huge you can have a
single cell that goes all the way down
your leg and so how does it how does a
signal that's generated in the bottom of
your spine travel in a timely manner all
the way down to the tip of your toe and
that's actually through electricity the
neurons can produce electrical impulses
that are called Action potentials that
travel extremely quickly through the uh
the cell on the inside of a neuron there
are less positive ions than there are on
the outside of a neuron and ions are
charged particles which are atoms that
have either gained or lost an electron
and that means that there are more
charged particles in one area than there
are in another area and so this
basically means that the outside of the
cell is positively charged compared to
the inside of the cell so the inside of
the cell is negatively charged the
outside of the cell is positively
charged and that state is known as
polarized because you have a positive
pole on the outside and a negative pole
on the inside
and the cell then can use this electric
potential across the membrane to
generate an electrical signal by
discharging that charge and so all the
cell has to do to discharge that charge
is open a channel in its membrane that
allows positive ions from the outside of
the cell to move to the inside itself
and that neutralizes that charge across
the membrane and that neutralization of
the charge is actually an electrical
signal that then moves down the axon in
sort of a wave manner so it doesn't
happen instantaneously there's a section
of the cell that opens up its ion
channels that part of the cell becomes
depolarized which then signals the
neighboring part of the membrane to
start opening channels so you can think
about it as sort of if you're holding a
rope in your hand and it's attached to
something at the other end of the room
and you give it a flick that wave that
you see traveling down the road that's
the electrical charge being discharged
across the membrane traveling down the
axon of a neuron and these Action
potentials once they get to the the end
of the axon which is the sort of sending
part of a neuron they signal the release
of chemicals which then can be detected
by other neurons so an analogy for how
neurons communicate is you can think of
it as as like the Postal Service you
have a signal being generated by the
person who's writing the letter which is
the cell that's sending the signal and
then the letter itself you can think of
as small chemicals that we we call
neurotransmitters that are chemicals
that are released into the extracellular
space the space around the cell to
communicate with other cells and most of
the time these neurotransmitters are
released at a point where two neurons
contact each other which is known as a
synapse and in the synapse there's a
tiny little space and so the neuron
who's sending the signal they have the
molecules that have been written you
know the letter that's been written and
they release it out into the synapse
which you can think about sort of the
Postal Service driving it around trying
to figure out where your house is and
then the receptors that receive that
signal receive that chemical are on the
surface of the receiving neuron and so
you can think of those receptors as sort
of a mailbox this is where the male gets
put the chemicals get detected the mail
gets put in your mailbox and then that
cell can open up its mailbox read its
mail figure out what it needs to do with
the piece of information that it just
got
so we've talked a lot about neurons
themselves how neurons work how they
communicate and then how they all
interact to form the nervous system as a
whole but thinking about that in a
practical sense you know as I'm sitting
here on the couch my nervous system is
doing so many different things for me I
can feel you know how my shoes feel on
my feet I can see everything around me I
can hear sounds around me and I can
respond and talk about neuroscience and
my brain controls all of these different
actions but your nervous system is also
doing things that you're not consciously
aware of all the time I mean it's it's
running your heart it's running your
breathing it's it's even working while
you're sleeping so your nervous system
is still working for you
all the time 24 7 your entire life which
is pretty incredible and so just just
this process of studying how the cells
of the nervous system compose the
nervous system and communicate and talk
to each other the applications are
almost endless it's like we've just sort
of dipped our toes into the ocean of of
the knowledge of the nervous system it's
like the final frontier you know to try
to figure out how all of this works and
there's so much more to learn it's just
very exciting